so our first speaker of this session
will be Joe renas who will be talking
about belief propagation decoding of
quantum channels bypassing quantum
messages so yes thanks Todd for
introduction and I'm excited to be here
to tell you about belief propagation
decoding I guess there's a little bit of
competition with the other talk or maybe
not everyone has realized that we've
started I'm also excited to be this is
coming back home for me because here we
have a nice picture of Seattle looking
to the west to the Olympic Olympic
Mountains and on the Olympic Peninsula
that's where I grew up so we'll see a
few more pictures of this throughout the
talk so I wanted to tell you about today
is in this archive preprint here so you
can check that out also okay so some
time ago I perhaps a long time ago I
won't say how long I heard a nice talk
from Ben Schumacher about his research
in quantum information theory and he was
talking about what does it mean to do
research in quantum information theory
in general and his basic comment was
well you take your favorite texts on
classical information theory open to a
chapter and translate the results are
the contents into quantum mechanical
language all right well we can try that
here's a book on classical information
theory it's modern coding theory by Tom
Richardson and rüdiger bonky so if
you're at qrp last year you recognized
really great gave a talk on all the
latest and greatest has happened in
modern coding theory since they
published this book but the main point
of the book is is that or one of the big
tools in in modern coding theory is
what's called belief propagation
decoding and it's there's actually not
one chapter to look at here for that but
but many and some of you are perhaps
actually making use of this belief
propagation decoding right now I I'm
certain that not everyone is listening
to the talk that carefully you might be
checking something under wire
and latest Wi-Fi standards have the
possibility of using codes that that use
belief propagation decoding one thing
you could do with it is download this
paper for instance okay it's not just a
tool that is useful you know because
that's the best that we can do it
actually can achieve capacity belief
propagation decoding for certain
ensembles and that was one of the things
that Rudy gur talked about last year
that's a big breakthrough in classical
information processing that so-called
spatially coupled low-density
parity-check codes can achieve capacity
under belief propagation decoding okay
so going back to this this observation
from Schumacher the question is well is
there quantum belief propagation
decoding okay so let me tell you just a
very vague overview of what belief
propagation is so it's a message passing
algorithm okay I'll say what that is in
a second so anyway it's an algorithm for
performing inference in a graphical
model okay so what's this inference part
so in in noisy channel coding the task
of the decoder is one of inference
because the decoder sees the output the
channel output and he knows that it was
one of the code words at the input but
needs to infer which one and there's a
statistical model for the input in the
output and so you want to do a
statistical inference and the code
itself the code constraints can be
described by a graphical model here's
here's one for a twenty bit code of rate
1/2 it's a linear code it has ten linear
constraints that are represented here so
there's ten different constraints on the
code words and all the each constraint
there's a there's a line to the various
variables that are involved in the
constraint and the sum of all the
variables that are connected have to be
0 okay that's the that's the constraint
now belief propagation is far far bigger
than just for decoding it's used in a
lot I mean in
statistics and machine learning can do a
lot of different things here for
instance here's a graphical model that
you might see in image processing and
the speed propagation algorithm is
somehow it uses this graphical model
here and there's some sort of message
passing on the nodes of the model I'm
not going to describe that now which
carries out this inference okay so it so
like I said it has a very wide
application actually an early precursor
is the beta piles of proximation and
statistical physics and it has it can be
on the inference it's also useful for
optimization and constraint satisfaction
so it's a it's a big tool in in
statistics and machine learning ok so
back to our question quantum belief
propagation decoding can we use yeah how
can we can we do this okay actually the
first thing to realize is that for
stabiliser decoding you can use the
classical algorithm so the stabiliser
decoding that you're probably familiar
with what you care about there is bit
flips and phase flip errors and already
the classical belief propagation
algorithm can do this so the point is
that there's a probability distribution
for those patterns the different
patterns of bit and phase errors and you
want to do inference on this probability
distribution and so the classical
classical algorithm will do this it's
actually optimal for poly channels
here's Polly so here's my little picture
of a channel the input is here obviously
and this sort of rough line means it's
quantum and there's the output it's so
it's optimal for poly channels and for
the erasure channel this stabilizer
decoding so you can use the classical
algorithm for that but it's not optimal
beyond this where so in these cases you
can basically work in this bit and phase
for the picture and that's sufficient
but for other channels like amplitude
damping it doesn't it's not optimal it's
not optimal in the sense that you
couldn't achieve capacity this way and
if you don't care about capacity you
just have a finite size code and you
want to know about the maximum say
fidelity that you could you could
transmit quantum information it wouldn't
be optimal for that either okay so
here's my though this is supposed to be
damned
anyway that didn't work very well okay
so let's if we want to make a quantum
belief propagation decoding and we're
following the Schumacher kind of thing
where we just translate into the quantum
language the simplest thing to do is
consider not the problem of quantum
information transmission right away but
classical information transmission
because more like the classical case so
if you just consider a CQ channel for
simplicity so here's the CQ channel has
classical input which is obviously
classical now because sort of digital or
something anyway and then but the output
is quantum alright so this is often
called W in the classical sorry in the
classical world channels are usually W
for whatever reason okay so what we want
to do just I mean from a very high level
we need to infer the channel input from
the quantum output right so we need to
build this box upside down W which takes
the quantum output and spits out
something classical and I mean this is
the task of the decoding I mean this
this this guy here is the decoder and
I'll skip that for a second
right so we need this decoder now the
point is of course since it does this
it's a measurement so it's not just
upside down W it's M right it's a
measurement okay so the point here is
that we need to build this measurement
and I need to make an important
distinction because if you know anything
about belief propagation already it's
you might think oh well the problem is
the quantum problem is gonna be very
similar to the classical one but
actually there's a there's a twist that
what you need to do in the coin the
classical problem is going to be
somewhat different than what you need to
do in the quantum case so what I'm
trying to stress here is that you need
to construct this measurement and in the
classical case there's it's not that you
really need to construct a measurement
you're just doing this inference and the
inference will come down to computing
marginals of certain probability
distributions but and then so for the
quantum case it's not enough to compute
these marginals all right
so this will become more concrete later
but I need to make this distinction
clear or make it import highlight it now
okay all right let me give you some the
results of the paper just so that if the
rest of the talk goes totally off the
rails then at least you have something
so we can find a belief propagation
decoding for a specific CQ channel which
just outputs pure states and and for a
specific class of codes called tree
codes they're just this factor grew
others so graphical representation turns
out to be a tree now interestingly this
also works for polar codes while this
thing is pretty weak so we'll get a
means for instance for a capacity
achieving decoder for lossy bosonic
channel for a certain kind of encoding
where you just use two coherent States
and maybe more interestingly you can use
it as part of a decoder for sending
quantum community quantum information
over amplitude damping channel so there
the ideas the polar coder is actually
build the quantum polar coder is built
out of things that you might use in this
classical quantum problem and we can
recycle this pure state decoder for
amplitude damping okay and so we end up
with an efficient capacity achieving
decoder for amplitude damping okay great
so here's a little outline of the rest
of the talk so nice picture of the
Olympics first coding set up just so
they're all on the same page about what
the problem is and the graphical models
which are called factor graphs in this
case and then a little bit about how
classical belief propagation works and
in a kind of strange presentation won't
look like what you would see in
Richardson or banca actually but it's
adapted for what's going to come later
the quantum belief propagation and then
the most important part is the many open
questions I think so I think this belief
propagation because it's so useful in
the classical classical information
processing and machine learning try to
figure out how to do quantum things with
it or
and so on and so the decoding problem is
one of them but there's you know many
other applications you could think about
and hopefully this will spur some some
interest in that and I have a lot of
open questions about just the decoder
and that will maybe motivate you to
solve all these problems okay so here's
our coding setup it's the usual Shannon
scenario it's very serious
it's a very serious affair so we have
stochastic iid noise we're not
considering the adversarial case we
don't care about adversarial errors and
we're not worried about errors in the
decoder we're not trying to do fault
tolerance fault on our decoding so
whoops give everything away so this is
the usual picture you have a message you
want to encode it and it goes over many
instances of the channel which is
describing the noise okay and we need to
build this decoder we want the encoder
and decoder I mean we want a high rate
code we want low error probability but
we also don't want to wait the age of
the universe in order for the decoder to
output the message so we need some kind
of efficient decoding so we're gonna use
linear codes at the at the encoder so as
I said that can be described in this
graphical way we actually get to a
little bit more in a moment and
importantly now for belief propagation
the kind of decoding we're doing is
bitwise so what we're going to try to do
is we know that the input let's say we
take we're interested in the average
performance so take a random codeword
and then with the assumption that you
had a random codeword tried to decode
the first bit like what was the value of
the first input given that you have all
of the outputs of the channel and maybe
what's the value of the second one just
do each one of them independently and
then those are your guesses for the bits
of the input and then hopefully that's a
code word then once you have that guess
you can recover what the message is so
if you want to do bitwise decoding what
you need to do is the classical problem
is just to marginalize the joint
distribution there's a joint
distribution describing you have a
random codeword at the input you have
the output actually the decoder gets to
see the exact value right so there's
some principle there's the joint
distribution of inputs and outputs x1 2
n is the input Y is the output you get
to see the output so the
the Y is fixed and you just want to know
what's the probability of say X I and
all of these guys so I just want to
marginalize the distribution now the
quantum problem is different
it's not about marginalizing anything
because what's happening is you know for
the two let's say we take the binary
case which we're going to do there's two
possible values say for the the bit of
to say the second second bit in the
codeword right here and given the fact
that the rest of the bits are in a
random codeword state that leads to two
possible quantum states at the output
there's just two possible quantum states
of the output so we need to perform the
hellström measurement there's no mystery
about it that's what the optimal decoder
is gonna do if you're doing bitwise
decoding the question is how to do the
hellström measurement okay but the
important thing is also to realize that
the classical problem it's enough to
marginalize this joint distribution of
course because you get to see exactly
just fix the value the analogous problem
to this which has been studied is to say
okay I have a density matrix which
describes the input in the output and I
want to marginalize the density matrix
that's not what we're doing here that
has been done before it's called quanta
belief propagation been done David
Berlin has has studied this Matt Lee
Fermat Hastings this is a totally
different algorithm so it has the same
sort of name but it's important to make
the distinction in the context I'm
talking about here I would call this
thing density matrix belief propagation
to make a distinction okay
so now our linear codes are have nice
factorized properties so let's just
consider an arbitrary distribution P a
probability distribution we have four
variables say and suppose it factorizes
in this way we can describe this here
with this graph so here are the
variables and here's the different
factors and you connect the variables to
the factors if you know if they show up
in the function and the point is when
you have a factorized probability
distribution it's easier to marginalize
easier to compute the marginals so
computing the marginals is a hard task
because it's it takes forever to loop
through all the possible states of the
other variables that you don't care
about but if there's some factorization
then this can be easier so here you save
by being able to compute the get rid of
3 & 4 by looking only at H and then
worry about two altogether with with the
rest of them
x2 ok so and it's just the distributive
law you're not it's not magic you're
just using the distributive law but it's
making it a little bit easier to compute
the marginals now the coding setup is
always has this nice factorized form
okay so here's the say the Joint
Distribution of inputs and outputs for
the classical case because the channel
is acting iid there's always just one
factor of the channel transition
probabilities for each input so that
shows up here and then there's the
codeword constraints but we have this
linear code so those factorize as well I
didn't write the factors here but there
they're written over here okay so
there's a joint input and output
distribution so here I should have this
is the graph this is a graph for for a
coding scenario I didn't write the Y
variable nodes the variable nodes around
nodes the factor I mean the ya factor
nodes are square but I didn't write the
Y ones because those are fixed at the
channel output so you can just consider
them to be part of the
the factor node for the channel itself
okay so it always has this factorized
form now classical classical belief
propagation decoding how does it work
okay so let's consider the case again
binary input channel and the first thing
to realize is in this case you only care
about the likelihood of the two the
likelihood ratio given the output so it
doesn't matter what the output alphabet
is or anything like that you get to see
the exact value of the channel output so
all you care about is the relative
probability of 0 versus 1 so this is all
you need to describe the action of the
channel so in other words the likelihood
is a sufficient statistic for the
statistics of the channel ok so we're
gonna work we're gonna use the
likelihoods
alright so let's come back to our
problem say we have this particular oops
this particular graph now if we're
interested in decoding x1 then we can
think of you know X 2 X 3 X 4 these are
in a random code word state but
basically say X 1 to Y 1 to n 2 the
outputs is sort of a channel and what we
want is the likelihood for this channel
okay that's what we need to compute ok
so let's assume that the factor graph
here is a tree so in fact this one is a
tree that's surprised I picked this
example so the tree just means of course
there's only one path between each any
two nodes so we can pick in this case I
picked X 1 is the root but you could
pick anything is the root now the way
classical belief propagation works one
way to think about it this is not
perhaps the standard way but basically
for each node in the graph you can
associate a channel from that node to
all of the its leaves all of the things
that it could eventually lead to at the
at the leaf ok and then what the
algorithm does is recursively compute
the likelihood that you want starting
from the leaves
okay so let's what do I mean exactly so
ok so for each node there's a channel to
the leaves now the ones at the leaf
those are just the
channels okay so that you already know
the likelihood for it that's the actual
physical channel okay there's also the
channel from say x3 to the leaf x4 to
the leaf x2 in fact those are all the
same as the ones before but there's some
likelihood for for this channel and
there's some likelihood for this channel
and what belief propagation is going to
do is combine those two likelihoods in a
certain way to get the likelihood for
the channel from this node to the leaves
to the leaves and then finally go to the
root right
okay so there's there's basically two
rules the belief propagation has there's
one rule for combining likelihoods when
the the branch point here is a is it
this check node or when it's a variable
node so here at the root there's three
branches coming out so these the
likelihoods of these three channels need
to be combined in a certain way and here
there's one it's a check node the
likelihoods of these two channels need
to be combined in a different way
okay so like I said the bleep
propagation is basically the rules for
these two combinations of likelihoods
and you can think of them as as two
kinds of channel convolution okay so
when you combine the likelihoods of say
W and W Prime according to belief
propagation rules you get a new
likelihood you could say well that's the
likelihood of a different channel the
convolution of the two channels that
just define that to be the convolution
operation and so and the rules are this
actually so encoded in this table are
the rules for combining likelihoods for
belief propagation but it's just in
terms of the channel convolution itself
so at the variable node it's the round
convolution say you have two channels WW
Prime you want to combine well what is
the effective channel that goes from the
variable node to two down two branches
if if the two branches are W and W prime
then the channel from the variable node
itself if there's a zero input to that
channel then it outputs this thing if
there's a one it outputs this one so
just it's just a little repetition code
where the effective channel at the
variable node is just whatever input it
gets it just gives those inputs to the
two descendants okay so you get the you
get both outputs from each of the two
channels okay so here W 0 means the
output you get when you put in 0 and W 1
is the output you get when you input W 1
so for this audience you should just
think of those as the density matrices
that come out of the channel now the
check convolution is more complicated it
doesn't doesn't give you this nice
repetition what it does is the input to
the check convolution channel is
basically controlling the parity of the
two outputs so you see here you get if
it's a 0 coming into the check node the
effective channel is saying well the
output is either this guy with two
zeroes to 0 inputs to the two sub
channels or both one so that's the even
parity case and then the other one if
it's a one that you flip it to odd
parity
so that's a little bit more complicated
but that's the check node convolution
okay so those are the two so very
cleverly the the notation is chosen so
that this convolution is corresponds to
the round nodes and so long okay now it
turns out that these rules will find the
exact marginal if the factor graph is a
tree okay and you can run the algorithm
concurrently basically for all the code
word bits it's not a big overhead to do
that so what I've been describing so far
you're only interested in particular by
itself but you can basically run it all
in parallel and most importantly for
applications to actual codes is that it
works on loopy graphs for low-density
parity-check codes that you might be
interested in so the tree it's great
that belief propagation works exactly on
a tree but tree codes aren't very good
actually nevertheless these low-density
parity-check codes that are
implementable they're not trees they
have loops in them but the loops are you
know tame enough such that the algorithm
sort of still gives a reasonable answer
so what you do there is you basically
run the algorithm until it kind of
converges and hope that it gets the
right result I won't go into too much
details on the loopy case but it's
important to realize that the tree case
is not the useful case for practice in
practice okay okay so let's take a small
we need a little break we did classical
belief propagation you see where we've
been and see where we're going we wanted
to talk about the quantum case now all
right
okay now we want to build the condom
belief propagation decoding
okay so the outputs are of the channel
of quantum there's no likelihood
function anymore that doesn't make sense
and we want to perform the hellström
measurement so our goal is slightly
different we don't get to just see that
you know we can't condition on the
channel output that doesn't mean
anything in the quantum case so okay
this is well this is what we have now
the leaves are spitting out quantum
states basically but otherwise it's the
same graph okay so the goal I mean the
question now is what we did in the
classical case was somehow combine the
likelihood information so that we could
make the decision for the decoding
problem is there some way to repackage
the outputs of the quantum channels at
the leaves here like we did for
likelihood or another way of thinking
about it that's probably maybe better is
well we want to make the hellström
measurement that goes with the channel
from X Juan say to the leaves and
suppose we know how to do the the
hellström measurement for this node to
the leaf and for this one to its leaves
and this one well this is just the
channel so if we knew how to do those
hellström measurements if we knew
exactly what they were how would we
combine them to make the hellström
measurement for the channel from the
root okay so we need some some way of
constructing the hellström measurement
for you know the convolve channels from
the hellström measurements of the two
inputs if we can do that then we can
build up a decoder okay so let's try the
simplest possible case classical inputs
that looks like the classical problem
we'll just take well to classical inputs
and we'll take two outputs which are
pure states so we might as well take
them to be qubits say their overlap is
cosine theta and we'll just just to fix
it we'll say that they're oriented so
that the optimal measurement to decide
between them is the Sigma X measurement
okay
so this is this is the simplest case I
could think of and all right so now we
have the ingredients we have the channel
here we have the factor graph and this
the rules for belief propagation that we
saw from the classical case so let's see
if they will give us anything useful in
the quantum case so the great thing
about the pure state channel so first of
all it is it seems like the simplest
thing you could you could you could
think about but you can see from the
variable node convolution this is good
news because this convolution also gives
pure state so if the two channels you're
interested in W and W prime have pure
state outputs then so does their
variable convolution because it's just
gonna be this okay so here the channel
is such that the output plus goes with
zero and minus goes with one that will
be convenient in a moment so the two
possible outputs are just plus theta
plus theta prime tensor product okay you
get two pure states again so it's a
channel of the same kind so you could
repackage that into one single qubit
with some unitary the unitary depends on
the angles okay so the angle is okay
this is the fine print so you the point
is since you get pure state outputs you
can just remap that into a qubit again
so you're back where you started so the
comment the convolved channel is again a
pure state Channel now you can also see
that the check node won't be like that
because it's a mixture so that seems
like oh this is not gonna work so you
get stuck for a while and then you
realize the cough it's actually really
simple unitary that will transform it
basically into a heralded mixture of
pure states the unitary okay it happens
to be 2c not gates but it doesn't really
matter what you can do is that the
outputs of the check node convolution
are two qubits but it's a classical
quantum state there's one qubit you can
measure and it doesn't disturb it at all
and it tells you which sector you're in
for the other key which which sector the
other qubit is in that is the other
qubit is in one of two pure states and
the angle depends on which sector you're
in so the angle is this theta
check convolution and the value of the
angle depends on J and okay the outputs
are still plus minus so by measuring
this extra cubed you can you can figure
out which sector you're in and so you're
basically also back to the pure state
case this is the fine print okay
so almost done now this is the algorithm
for this particular problem can run
through it so okay we're at the we're
interested in x1 so we need to do the
variable node convolution of these two
guys so these are the qubits sorry these
these are the qubits over here this is
the factor graph that goes with it so
there's the qubit that goes with one
there's the qubit that comes through the
channel from three so we need to combine
those two but we also need to do this
check node convolution of two and four
okay so let's just reorder the qubits
with the swap gate and then we can do
the convolution for the variable node
that's what this unitary here we need to
know the angles that go into this but
okay we know that and so at the output
you get one qubit the other one can be
discarded and it's in this this new
state on the other side of things we do
the check node convolution so to combine
qubits the outputs from two and four and
we get this state where okay now we need
to know we need to measure which sector
we're in and then we can continue so
once we've done that so we've combined
these two guys and we have this this
channel here we need to combine the
result at the variable node okay so we
have we have two pure state channels we
can check which sector we're in for this
check node convolution and the variable
node convolution is simple but it needs
to know the angles involved and that you
need to feed it in the classical the
classical data to know which SEC which
sector you're in okay and then you can
recombine all the information into one
qubit and then perform the hellström
measurement on that cubed so that's the
last step here so that's how you
construct the algorithm the circuit from
the factor graph basically so you can do
that what's what's going on is basically
you could think of it as sort of message
passing where the qubits are being
passed around also some classical bits
these behave like a sufficient statistic
for this class of channels so you can
always describe the convolutions and
everything for pure state channels with
some angles and some classical bits just
like it's kind of like the likelihood
ratio so in this case we're gonna have
to decode all the codeword bits
sequentially because okay we'll have to
run this for x1 and then reverse it make
the measurement here and then reverse it
all and then run it for x2 and reverse
it and run it for x3 so in the end you
get a order n-squared implementation of
all of the hellström measurements okay I
don't think you really have time to talk
about the polar coding case let me skip
this but just how you can build the
polar decoder for it and you would get
this order N squared decoder for the
amplitude damping case okay so the open
questions in the last three seconds
[Music]
alright so this was the algorithm for
one specific channel what about other
channels what if we tried to do
classical coding for the amplitude
damping channel for instance not a
quantum the previous slide was about
quantum communication okay what about
loops I said a couple of times that the
tree case is is good in theory but in
for high rate codes that's not going to
be the interesting case so as I said the
the spatially coupled ensemble can
achieve capacity could you could you
achieve capacity for the C cube pure
state case so there's going to be loops
in the factor graph how do you even run
it in that case maybe we can use the
density matrix belief propagation the
classical just marginalize the
the density matrix for the description
of the problem and then used this to
build the hellström measurement somehow
it's not really clear to me for this you
need to have some maybe sufficient
statistics come out of this and ok when
you when you run this loopy case you're
not getting a global tree but locally it
will look like a tree so how do we turn
the local tree into a global tree then
we can use some tensor Network methods
here cleanly the factor graph is a
graphical method it has some relation to
tensor network but I don't know what it
is now in the classical case there many
approximate algorithms for belief
propagation one of them is Junction tree
which is basically just glom all the
nodes together until you make a tree and
maybe something like that could work
here but I don't know so we were doing
bitwise decoding another thing that you
might do in the classical classical case
is block wise decoding which is called
Viterbi decoding try it I don't this is
also unknown
well can we could try to have a fully
quantum version and I think the biggest
open question is what about all these
other tasks so this is just one tiny
example of a quantum belief propagation
where it's really a quantum algorithm
but what about for constraint
satisfaction or for optimization or
other inference tasks can we you know
expand this to different cases ok so
thanks for your attention
okay we have time for a few questions
so right here thanks for the nice talk
um I was I was wondering whether
disturbance by this Hofstra measurement
plays a role in when considering bitwise
versus block-wise decoding yeah so you
have to do something like I mean the
statement is kind of like what Aaron was
talking about yesterday you're gonna do
the sequential measurements you just
look what the error is that when you
when you do that and you use some Union
bound to a non commutative Union bound
to two bound there's so it's only going
to be good when all the bitwise decoders
are good okay but in the polar case
that's that's guaranteed
have you thought about analogies to
these techniques for maximum entropy
inference rather than maximum likelihood
well the short answer is no because I
don't know what Maxim entry inference is
I think it sounds like a distribution
and then use your known error rate to
try to infer what state you got sorry
can you say that again is where you are
taking a thermal distribution to looking
out for your somewhat known error rate
oh I see okay so I it sounds like it
would be very useful to do but I don't
know off the top of my head anything
about it it's mark over there in the
corner okay for the case of the obstacle
channel The Lost Channel have you
thought about how you could actually
implement these unit areas usually right
okay so for the pure loss case you can
see that the decoder would be efficient
in the number of gates you need but it's
it's still yet another matter to see how
you would do the gates no I haven't
thought about that I suspect it's very
difficult to do them with linear optics
say or something like that but I haven't
thought about that at all I think so the
first step is to see like okay we don't
need to do an infinite number of things
and then yeah someone who's actually
also more knowledgeable about how to
actually implement certain gates needs
to look at that cuz I could try it but I
think it will take me too long
other questions
all right then that's a thank Joe again
[Applause]